[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas mal pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les hommes vitesse que les hommes il ya
des clochards dans les métros ici c'est
chacun course à dornach la posture les
gens ont certaines courses car de l'eau
fiennes ont répondu mon succès la veille
en
on s'abandonne et si ça te fait plaisir
je veut bien sourire mais ce ne sera pas
un sancerre je préfère te dire
parce qu'une fois plaisir
m'enfuir mais je tiendrai même pas la
distance et sans vouloir te plaît
pourquoi veux tu que je pense
[Musique]
le temps
jeux d'eau
[Musique]
depuis longtemps
pas tous les cours les plus urgents des
ogm dans la poitrine mais les gardiens
heureusement on nous en a sauvé le
promets
bien sûr on mange tout ce qu'on nous dit
on la détresse tu la tendresse
y'a plus personne ce qui se fait plaisir
je veux bien ce mot mais quand je vois
le présent j'aime pas la glisse
moi ce qui me ferait plaisir c'est de
revenir en avant est en avance elle sans
vouloir te crève offense pourquoi veux
tu que je danse
[Musique]
je
évidemment on pouvait le bonheur c'est
comme le thon faut s'en servir
appréciant je voudrais sourire sans
réfléchir et de trouver ma part
d'enfance et pour ça j'ai besoin de
silence
pourquoi veux tu que je doute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a dû
j'adore j'adore ce type on a dit merci
c'est nouveau single de l'adie et nadine
[Applaudissements]
d'un délire à nous montrer bientôt parce
que tu es avec toi bats je voulais dire
voilà j'ai travaillé sur le prochain
single de nazim et voilà à vous verrez
pas c'est vrai ça travailler dessus
ouais bah il m'a demandé un petit peu
musicalement de l'aider ghazi parce que
c'est beau non pas à ferrero ne vois pas
ce qu'on me prend pour un mythe ou est
ce que c'est vrai ou pas non c'est vrai
et grâce à des grâces a toi jéjé
passagers passent un step on peut le
dire voilà les gars je suis un petit peu
dans la musique jeune âge écosse adrián
et on les fabrique la guéguerre à
regarder je vais reconnaître tout de
suite n'allait pas un truc n'apporterait
pas un truc comme ça allait
[Musique]
aussi belle que je
oda lui ont valu c'est la ville a
composé et pourquoi veux tu que je danse
c'est un tube une petite dernière vers
la guitare
pourquoi du feu la wii allez c'est pas
utah soit noste chemist
quoi
ça c'est nazi
aux seules forces du changement c'est la
douche